hello and welcome to this video playing
the Dark Passenger we don't have a name
there okay should be I don't have a good
score against this person minus 24 wins
six losses okay I'm trying the Queens
gambit accepted and opening that I have
not yet studied in big detail so i hope
i'm not getting what getting crushed by
someone someone who knows the opening
well check hmm okay interesting i can
just go back to the seven on I go and I
go back to yourself don't want to trade
the bishops just yet but ok here age
three I probably have to take on a three
that also doesn't look too great yeah I
was not very logical here to try to
avoid this the bishop train and then
played in a way that some have to take
on f3 ok anyway now that's probably not
terrible yet but also not very good
admitted him ok kick this back
yeah not very attractive admittedly but
that's what you get I should have played
Bishop d7 really pretty bad mistake
yeah why this better long-term with this
bishops and potential play on the C file
the only thing I have I don't have a
very clearly bad piece it still feels
kind of kind of solid I try to do
something your queen age 4 95 maybe get
some peace play on the Kings side and
piling up them ever cheek Knight to f6
it's got f3 at least let three trade is
really not great ok let's go back even
though that means that night edge
forwards a queen age for was a bit of a
bit of ways that's pretty bad 9023 for
example is a pretty good idea okay
is probably as well no idea why I went
to f6 actually g3 that's h5 just not
very sophisticated trap I can better
call the trap it's really very very
simple stuff ok I still have to make
some kind of oh don't know why allowed
that I me not not that it is that great
maybe but still ok 93 as a move no we
can take g5 play Knight f3 but I can
take here right and check on on the on
g6 King f1 cringy tool king even when I
captioned by that anyway thinking about
the details it's just a waste of time
when you have to play the move kingi one
I don't see a window amazingly enough
probably me just being blind but I don't
see a win k didn't didn't take I take G
to stat something I just go here
93 at the end rook moves once you fine
yeah anyway let's be quick I can play g3
just like that maybe hmm that could
could be yeah okay no choice I guess dr.
drew move i have to go at five just try
and trying to try to try to kill him di
1 f 2
f was also threat
cheeks I'll take with the Queen
Jim any option left some with something
weird Bishop d7 may be looking at the
age three night but I think I can take
yeah I can take out two in that case can
take with the Queen f2 is detect roughly
a million times yeah I can just take it
right
now had a very bad position really but
TM allowed allowed enormously an
enormous attack check on age three as
well and that wind stuff 94 probably
also in stuff Jay King g2 maybe I'm
check here yeah okay yeah let's win
material now take the rook there is no
counter attack right no
least I don't see any counter check
white resigns yeah it was a lucky win I
was essentially outplayed here
strategically and I think just some some
good defensive moves would would be okay
like g3 or just takes take some squares
away it got this was not so ridiculous
yeah I'm not sure I thought I thought
this is good actually trying to go on
that light squares the computer gives
wider very clear CH one point something
one point one point one Kim going to see
forest idea what he gave me a enormous
amount of tempest was strange I mean a
g5 was very clear that it happens yeah
and now I took them the thing is it is
actually really not that clear the
computer is giving 000 at least with a
somewhat shallow depth so takes check
check I didn't see you in I saw that
this is this is of chess of course a
dangerous for white but I didn't see
that it wins like this the engine gives
0.1 yeah but this you cannot really be
completely we cannot rely entirely on
the engine on a relatively low death you
have to give it a little bit more time
because possible attacks might lie a
little bit to find the future I think
you should have still taken I mean here
yeah this is not probably not working I
don't believe it a night here and here
white can go Bishop d7 ha they move that
I saw one move later as an as an
opportunity of a possibility there's
really a funny move and takes the night
computer chips at five by the way now I
have low good square and if I take them
hi this is trapped pretty amazing and
the engine wants to do this and then
give the exchange em with equality after
g5 if you have to do that otherwise the
night is stretched and now night g5
takes TX king of seven equality ok ok
this one and after n5 i'm winning mm-hmm
chan chan are 25 was actually possible
ok but it's a full rook so it was ok
yeah he gave me an enormous count to
play there with night edgy five with the
tempo and yeah very difficult to to play
with white maybe he could have defended
but it's very difficult to do in a good
scam ok well thanks for watching